Agora que passamos por todos os elementos do VQE, vamos
resumir o que aprendemos e ver como um computador quântico o executa.
Começamos com nosso estado de referência cuidadosamente escolhido, circuit parametrizado,
escolha inicial de parâmetros e um Hamiltoniano.
Passamos esses elementos para nosso computador quântico.
Antes que o Hamiltoniano possa ser executado no estado ansatz,
precisamos fazer o pré-processamento clássico do circuit
para torná-lo legível pelo hardware quântico em um processo chamado transpilation.
Também é importante aproveitar ao máximo
a arquitetura dos qubits no hardware real para obter os melhores resultados.
Esses processos geralmente são realizados automaticamente para que não precisemos
conhecer explicitamente a conectividade dos qubits,
as fidelidades dos gates e assim por diante.
Agora a tarefa é medir o estado resultante
e estimar o valor esperado, que será ainda
otimizado por um otimizador clássico.
Essa medição é realizada rotacionando a base de medição
e depois combinando os resultados das medições para obter o valor esperado.
Esse resultado parametrizado é então alimentado
no otimizador clássico, que encontra novos parâmetros para o estado.
Em seguida, o processo se repete.
Um pré-processamento clássico cria um novo circuit parametrizado
e aplicamos o mesmo Hamiltoniano de antes.
Note que em todo o processo VQE só alteramos os estados
por meio dos parâmetros que vão se aproximando cada vez mais do estado fundamental.
Repetimos isso até ficarmos satisfeitos com o resultado.
E é isso.
Meu nome é Victoria Lipinska e este foi um curso de variational quantum eigensolver.